so the main difference between like a
new club that just popped out versus a
club with a long long history is
how much respect it has from other clubs
surrounding it right so as i mentioned
if you're like a long time club that
means you have at least a few people who
either like came out of your club or
went to your club
and became really popping off you know
went on like news medias or just carried
your club to the surface right and that
carries a lot of value in the hosting
industry it it's weird to me that japan
puts hosts on this like pedestal
but then
you know how it is if you're if you're a
woman doing the exact same job reversed
it's like yeah
oh yeah it's like you know you're like
the
scam of society yeah it's bizarre really
because it is very double standards even
if we
had that in the west we i don't think
we'd be putting the hosts on tv and
stuff like that but japan it's just like
dude this guy's sick bro he like talks
to girls all day oh you're willing
oh [ __ ] you're disgusting yeah yeah the
[ __ ] yeah sorry i should have mentioned
but i think as well like that's like
going back to like roland right like i
think the reason why it became like that
is because in a lot of ways you know i
think it's accepted that a guy can be
like that right and at least in japanese
society
that's a character like yeah this is
good but if one of them acted the same
way i think i think if there was like a
female equivalent of roland it wouldn't
happen the same way unfortunately you do
have good examples of that though yeah a
lot of huge um cosmetic shot shows right
now coming from the background right i
like that
but like you mentioned
roll around roland's impact on this
industry is impeccable yeah something
you cannot measure with just numbers
yeah also he sold himself as a
personality exactly on tv whereas we
haven't really had that for the female
like
no yeah so you join a new club right
let's say uh you're you're a rookie
you're [ __ ] at your job you're just
terrible
what's the experience i would have being
terrible in like one of the old amazing
perfect respected clubs versus being in
a club that's kind of [ __ ] and like
small and they just kind of like
like even get a job in that in that
sense well let's say you got it right
let's say you got it and then you
started [ __ ] up like you know you
couldn't get any clients like how would
they
because i can imagine that they don't
treat you the they're not like oh oh
it's okay it's okay
but i imagine the one that's like kind
of worse off it's like i'll do it i mean
the best example i can give is
imagine being in like unknown ass
[ __ ] you know consulting company
versus being in [ __ ] boston
consulting right right right you know
the pressure that's a very specific
example yeah look the pressure you have
at boston consulting doesn't derive from
the fact that you know
you suck but it's because this is the
company you know values we uphold
are you reaching that standard right now
you know if you're not we have a
thousand other recruits outside lining
up to take your placement versus an
unknown as club it's like
we could fire you but we'll have nobody
else we're gonna enjoy paying people
that's the difference right right
so like is it how dangerous is the
industry
yeah how dangerous well actually that's
a really great um question because
you know
from the old times other host clubs are
known to have a lot of violence involved
in them yeah meaning if you're not
performing well if you're you know
slacking you know
your boss might kind of like slap you
around
and
what do you mean slap around like like
like a little like like
no bro i'm talking about that you're
sleeping and they'll [ __ ] bash your
head and [ __ ] you know wait wait like
like like [ __ ] good fellas
like even in my host club
not not within there but previous to
joining there i've had
stories told to me from those people
there that you know they were kind of
falling asleep and then they got smacked
in the head so hard that their [ __ ]
tooth chipped and [ __ ]
bro like because i was sleeping yeah
exactly just because they were like not
so you know responsive and whatnot
even within my host club we would have
like meetings to go over like
statistics was billing well there's a
good headphone you know because even if
you're not billing if you're
contributing so that the girls are
drinking yeah they will respect you
right because that means you're doing
your job yeah exactly that means you
contribute to the actual revenue alright
but if you're just like you're not even
catching girls outside and when the
girls sit with you you're some boring
ass [ __ ]
they're going to [ __ ] [ __ ] about it
and that's the main way to make you quit
right by keep putting on the spotlight
and be like you [ __ ] suck they can't
just tell you to like [ __ ] off no
because i mean you know that's not the
way that's the way japanese people do it
you know they're what they like shame
you publicly until you quit bro yeah
honestly yeah that's [ __ ] up
truthfully it's so funny i mean i mean
regular companies do that too yeah
that's because they have lifetime
contracts yeah yeah yeah
it starts at school because
if they're willing to like slap you in
the head why aren't they willing to tell
you to not turn up to work tomorrow i
don't know
yeah i love that i was like i have no
like i have no like resistance to like
actually smack you in the back of the
head but i don't have the heart to tell
you to quit
everything
if you prevail from this you know
agonizing pain that's such [ __ ]
bro come on it is a real true phenomenon
where if you're strong enough to prevail
this challenge that's given to you yeah
that means you could become a man i
agree in some sense i don't know about
that i think i only works in anime
tell me you're a [ __ ] ass excuse come
on tell me
there is a challenge and there is being
beaten up in your world
host industry is not some like you know
[ __ ] sugar coated powder i'm not sure
no no it's not sound
we've established that it's dodgy as
[ __ ] in there
you have to know your you know street
knowledge yeah if you don't have any
street abilities you're going to get
[ __ ] you know bulldozed over yeah
yeah
of course yeah that's a fact frightening
it is some form of it's a noble
challenge that one must undertake to
become oh no this guy is that the way
i'm putting it or is it i'm putting in a
way that it's like rolling in the mud
and wrestling until one of them chokes
to death
like you know
that's the kind of that's the kind of
challenge that you have to understand
did you did you think that analogy was
better
i think i think it reflects the
situation or at least reflects the
reality of the situation
do you think it's [ __ ] up
it's
[ __ ] up but but you also think there's
a point to it yeah absolutely no it's
not [ __ ] up bro no it's no it's fun
who am i to judge you literally just
said you're rolling around the mud until
one of them like i'm pretty sure like
like gladiators did that back like the
roman empire
look in in any business right there is a
reason as to why the whole thing
transpired to become what it is yeah
you have to respect what came before you
of course you understand why it's the
way it is that's the whole you know core
of understanding what a culture is
mm-hmm
but then there are you know sometimes
there are cultures that should maybe be
changed just just because just because
something's been established doesn't
mean you can't
i feel japan though i'm sensing some
vocals
whatever
profile i just i just i just think
generally that's uh you know i
understand why this these kind of
stories can happen in the industry i'm
not gonna say that it's funny that it's
not [ __ ] up yeah i mean
let's just let's just let's just break
this down you're literally trying to say
that getting your teeth kicked in is
my sister apologies for not making this
clear there is a huge difference between
having a disciplined way of conducting
your business versus
violence because violence is really
frowned upon
yeah no matter what
you're finally attacking you can agree
with that
you're right jan water is wet
how is like xenophobia and racism within
the host yeah because i've heard there's
plenty of the astro man yeah because
like i've heard that some a lot of host
clubs actually don't let foreign no no
they don't because like what are they
going to do well i mean what if they
want to have like a good time trying to
like interact with the locals can't
communicate
if you can speak japanese in your farm
would they let you in if you can't speak
japanese and you're a foreigner you have
a chance a chance you have a chance yeah
that's interesting i mean survive the
beating and we'll give you a drink
this is this this is the same with
almost all other japanese businesses
that are nightlife related that is true
foreigner most likely they'll be like
and then not accept you yeah yeah yeah i
mean some restaurants [ __ ] just yeah
right yeah let alone you know in our
life stuff this is like going back to
the discrimination thing that i just
mentioned like isn't you know because
you're you know you're a harpoo uh am i
now yeah oh yes you are yes yeah
[ __ ] i don't know you like to know where
they'll
like five billion times you know and uh
from what i've seen yeah jerry you could
i'm sure you can uh say if i'm right or
wrong if you don't look 100 in japanese
i just assume you're like foreign
so how does that you know because that
comes into a pla that comes into play
a lot in japan
for sure
so how does it come into play in a host
club how many how many times were you
nihongo joseph at a host club every
single time yeah right so
how surely they must in some senses
they're like oh you're not you're not
japanese bro you're like you're like the
gimmick bro you're funny yeah yeah yeah
yeah each time each time so did you use
that to your advantage or did you like
try and fight against it
as i mentioned to you guys before i had
no interest in talking to girls who had
no life experience or who had no
interest in life experience so i would
come across some people that say like
you know i asked them you know do you
want to go abroad i've been to this
country you wanna know more about and
they're like no i'm okay with just
staying in japan i'll be like
okay next weirdly weirdly coming it
happens a lot bro happens a lot but you
know i skipped those girls because i
have nothing they want to talk to them
about yeah but until i found find the
people that want to know more about you
know living abroad
yes yeah
that's when i shine